[Music]
this is airspeeder an australian company
that's trying to create a racing series
for electric vertical takeoff and
landing or evtol aircraft it looks a
little bit like pod racing from the star
wars films or anti-gravity racing games
that i used to play when i was a kid the
idea is that ev tolls made by airspeeder
sister company alauda will race around a
track in the name of entertainment
innovation and promotion of their
aircraft kinda like formula one for the
sky now while the idea of flying car
racing may have been around for years
most of the companies i found were still
in the initial design phase but airspeed
to have an actual aircraft and pilots so
is flying car racing about to become a
reality well maybe one day but right now
it's not quite there yet
so we're going to do this by looking at
where the company is right now where it
wants to be
and then examine what it needs to do to
get there but let's start with where
airspeeder are headed
the company plans to create a new racing
series which they will charge teams to
enter and then sell the broadcast rights
too instead of investing in physical
race courses airspeeder told me they
plan on using augmented reality to
project a circuit into the pilot's field
of view and onto streamed footage that
means that races could be held pretty
much anywhere the aircraft is certified
airspeeder also told me that by creating
an e-vetol race they hope to develop new
safety standards and infrastructure for
ev toll aircraft and there's a
precedence here motorsport has often
been used by the automotive industry as
a way to receive investment try out new
technologies and sell vehicles and yes
allowed as aim is to sell their evite
aircraft to those wealthy enough to buy
them no release date yet but the company
told me that at launch they'll be priced
around the same as quote a high-end
hyper car
so where are we right now well after
receiving funding in 2019 airspeeder has
hired former motorsport engineers
recruited some pilots from a range of
sporting backgrounds flown allowed as
aircraft and even conducted its first
race kinda it was a really short one a
945 feet drag race between two aircraft
the airspeeder told me was part of their
testing still this guy got champagne for
winning
so if they've conducted a race and hired
pilots what do they need to do to close
the gap between these two points well
let's start with those pilots because
right now they're not actually in the
aircraft at all speeder currently only
have certification for a remote pilot
license and their current generation of
aircraft isn't even designed to be
crewed which means the person
controlling the aircraft in this video
is actually on the ground
right now that makes this very similar
to something called fpv drone racing
which is already hugely successful and
is estimated to rake in hundreds of
millions of dollars each year even if
airspeeders newly signed races could
step aboard their aircraft they'll need
training first as most of them come from
motor racing or fpv drone racing
backgrounds and aren't actually aircraft
pilots
and then there's the circuits as
airspeeder aren't building a physical
racecourse they're going to have to
figure out how to beam a precision
virtual course in perfect real time to
both the audience and the pilots when i
spoke to airspeeder ceo he told me that
the company is working with the
australian aviation authority on
certification working with its partners
on a virtual race course and that a lead
pilot is training their new pilots for
future flights even if airspeeder
overcomes these obstacles it still needs
to attract an audience to make this a
profitable venture
so to turn anti-gravity racing from
science fiction into a bonafide reality
airspeeder is going to need additional
certification
trained pilots a new aircraft that can
be piloted
and a way of beaming all of that course
information to pilots and the audience
if all that happens then airspeeder
could have some of the key ingredients
for an interesting new racing series
what's yet to be seen is how many people
will tune in and watch
[Music]